(Coughing.)
Measles.
Mumps.
Meningitis.
The flu.
When you think of life-changing college experiences,
that’s not what comes to mind, right?
That’s why Emory University takes student
immunization so seriously.
One infected student can impact the whole
community.
In fact, immunization compliance is so important
to Emory, your class registration is tied
to it.
(UGH!
No!)
Without up-to-date immunization records on
file with Emory Student Health Services, you
won’t be able to register for classes.
The good news is, submitting your records
is as easy as logging on to Emory Student
Health Patient Portal…
Downloading your school-specific immunization
form to be signed and verified by a doctor…
Entering your immunization dates…
And uploading a copy of your verified and
signed immunization form!
That’s all it takes to be immunization compliant.
Let’s all do our part to keep the Emory
community healthy, and helping every student
be well and excel.
Go to student health dot Emory dot E-D-U for
more information or to access the patient
portal and get started!